the first is column drop column drop is
probably the easiest at its narrowest
viewport each element simply stacks
vertically one on top of the other as
things get wider the elements expand
until the first breakpoint is hit at the
first break point instead of having all
the elements stacked two elements are
now side by side and the third element
is underneath the elements keep
expanding as the viewport gets wider
until the next breakpoint is hit and
then things reflow to a three-column
layout generally once the viewport hits
a maximum width the columns hit a
maximum size and instead of getting
wider margins are added to the left and
right so how do we code this let's start
with the smallest viewport we have our
three divs inside of a container div the
container is a flex container with flex
rap rap next I've set the width of all
of the divs to 100% to give me that
stacked layout because this is just a
sample I'll pick a totally random
breakpoint at 450 pixels I want the dark
blue div to be twenty five percent of
the viewport width and the light blue
div to be 75 percent and I want to keep
the green at the full width I'm going to
add a new media query that checks if min
width is greater than or equal to 450
pixels and then change the width of dark
blue to 25 and light blue to
seventy-five percent a lot of 3rd
breakpoint at five hundred and fifty
pixels and make the dark blue div 25%
the light blue tip fifty percent and the
green div to be twenty five percent to
get that to happen I'll add a new media
query that test for screen and min with
550 pixels inside that media query I'll
set the width for dark blue and green to
twenty five percent and light blue to
fifty percent let's try it in the
browser we're all stacked at 400 pixels
at 450 our layout changes and again at
pixels perfect